INTRODUCE OUR GUESTS.
ADJOINING IS NOT, THE AUTHOR OF
THE NEW BOOK, A PHENOMENAL BOOK,
RESISTANCE AT ALL COSTS.
HOW TRUMPETERS ARE HATING
AMERICA.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KEMI STRAW
ALSO ALONG WITH THE AUTHOR OF
THE BOOK POWER GRAB, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, JASON CHAFFETZ.
PUBLIC CONGRESSMEN MATT GAETZ
EARLIER TODAY WAS ACTUALLY
THROWN OUT OF THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
WHY?
I'M SURE YOU ARE A FRIENDLY GUY.
>> IS VERY BIZARRE.
ON SEPTEMBER 12, THE JUDICIARY
CHAM AND LAUNCH THE IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY AND TODAY ADAM SCHIFF
REMOVED ME AS A MEMBER OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE FROM THE
DEPOSITION HE WAS TAKING.
THIS IS PROOF THAT DEMOCRATS
CAN'T WIN A FAIR ELECTION, THEY
CAN'T WIN A FAIR DEBATE, AND
THEY ABSOLUTELY CANNOT RUN IT
FOR IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY BECAUSE
THEY ARE STACKING THE DECK.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING THEY
CAN TO LIMIT ACCESS TO WITNESS
AND EVIDENCE.
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWING US TO CALL
WITNESSES AND BY THE WAY, THE
REPUBLICANS HAD A WITNESS LIST
AND IT WOULD BE ADAM SCHIFF
ADAM SCHIFF.
SO LOOK, WE ARE GOING TO KEEP
FIGHTING TO GET TO THE FACTS
HERE ABOUT TIME AND AGAIN WE SEE
THAT ADAM SCHIFF IS RUNNING A
KANGAROO COURT AND THAT SHOULD
MATTER TO SENATORS WHO MAY HAVE
TO ULTIMATELY CONSIDER THIS
IMPEACHMENT THAT IT WAS DONE IN
A TOTALLY SHOT WAY.
EVEN REPUBLICANS DIDN'T TREAT
BILL CLINTON'S BED.
THEY HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
MINORITIES SUBPOENAS AND HAVE
LAWYERS IN THE ROOM ASKING
QUESTIONS.
THEY WENT THROUGH THAT WITH THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
THEY ALLOWED US TO ASK MUELLER
QUESTIONS.
THEY DIDN'T LIKE THE RESULT SO
NOW THEY ARE TRYING TO RESHUFFLE
THE DECK AND I THINK IT'S A
SHAMEFUL DAY FOR THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Sean: THEY ANNOUNCE THEY
HAVE MANY REASONS, IF THIS ONE
DOESN'T WORK OUT, THEY WILL FIND
ANOTHER ONE.
THE BOOK IS PHENOMENAL.
I THINK IT'S A DEFINING MOMENT
FOR THE COUNTRY.
TIE-DYED AND ALSO TO UKRAINE,
ADAM SCHIFF, PELOSI, THE
IMPEACHMENT MADNESS, AND THE MOB
AND THE MEDIA.
>> WELL, THIS IS ONE OF THE
DAMAGES THAT THE RESISTANCE IS
CAUSING THAT I TALK ABOUT IN THE
BOOK.
WE HAVE TWO MODERN IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRIES AND IN BOTH CASES, THE
PARTY IN CHARGE WILL BEND OVER
BACKWARDS TO MAKE SURE IT WAS
DONE IN A FAIR AND OPEN MANNER
BECAUSE THEY UNDERSTOOD THAT
THEY NEEDED TO TREAT IMPEACHMENT
AS THE SOMBER AND SERIOUS TOOL
THAT IT IS AND PROVE TO
AMERICANS THAT THEY WERE
CONDUCTING AN INQUIRY IN A FAIR
MANNER.
WE NOW HAVE A HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
MAJORITY THAT HASN'T EVEN HAD A
VOTE AND TAKE IN THE
ACCOUNTABILITY ON THE FLOOR TO
TAKE RESPONSIBILITY FOR THIS.
THEY ARE HOLDING THEIR
PROCEEDINGS IN SECRET, THEY ARE
DENYING THE WHITE HOUSE THE
RIGHT TO CALL THEIR OWN
WITNESSES AND REPUBLICANS THE
RIGHT TO CROSS-EXAMINE WITNESSES
OR EVEN BE PRESENT.
THIS IS NOT HOW AMERICANS EXPECT
IMPEACHMENT TO BE TREATED AND
THESE ARE THE KIND OF DAMAGE TO
INSTITUTIONS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE WITH US FOR A LONG TIME IN
THIS COUNTRY AND THAT ARE
IMMENSELY CONCERNING.
>> Sean: WE WON'T HAVE A
COUNTRY IF THIS CONTINUES.
THIS BRINGS US TO THE IG REPORT.
CONGRESSMAN CHAFFETZ, IT'S BEEN
TAKING A LONG TIME AND WE HEARD
THE END OF THIS WEEK, NOW WE ARE
IN THE BEGINNING OF NEXT WEEK, I
CAN NEVER GET A STRAIGHT ANSWER,
BUT AT SOME POINT, ARE WE GOING
TO SEE PREMEDITATED FRAUD ON A
FISA COURT AND PEOPLE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE SPYING ON A
PRESIDENT AND SHOWING CAMPAIGN
TRANSITION IN A PRESIDENT?
>> IT HAS BEEN GOING ON FOR AN
EXCEPTIONALLY LONG TIME.
EVIDENTLY THERE'S BEEN BEEN
INTRAAGENCY DEBATE AND REALLY A
FOOD FIGHT, IF YOU WILL, ABOUT
THE CLASSIFICATION ISSUES.
YOU REMEMBER IN THE LAST REPORT
PUT OUT BY HOROWITZ, THERE WERE
ONLY SEVEN WORDS OR SO THAT WERE
REDACTED THE DEMOCRATS THREW A
FIT THAT THEY COULDN'T SEE THE
WHOLE THING.
IT THIS COULD HAVE TEN OR 20% OF
THE REPORT REDACTED.
SENATORS, BASED ON MY OWN --
>> Sean: IS THAT DIRECTOR RAY,
WHO HAS NOT SHOWN ANY
WILLINGNESS TO CLEAN UP THE
GREATEST LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
IN THE WORLD?
IS THAT HIM?
>> I HAVE NOT SEEN ANY EVIDENCE
THAT DIRECTOR RAY HAS BEEN
COOPERATIVE.
I THINK PERHAPS YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT THE CIA, THE NSA, THERE
ARE OTHERS.
I THINK MR. CLAPPER,
MR. BRUNNING, THEY ARE
BEHIND-THE-SCENES FIGHTING AS
BEST AS THEY CAN.
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA, THEY ARE
FIGHTING AS BEST AS THEY CAN.
I THINK YOU NEED TO LOOK AT WHAT
MR. COMEY, THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI, AND HIS INTERACTION WITH
BRENNAN IN PARTICULAR, WHAT SORT
OF COLLUSION WAS HAPPENING
WITHIN OUR GOVERNMENT AND
OVERSEAS?
THAT'S THE DEEP CONCERN.